dreams of another ceasefire dashed
as gunfire rings out in Horton
Sudan's capital is suffocating from the
shock of violence and residents are
fleeing to nearby areas on Mass
as the city's infrastructure crumbles
hospitals across Gordon have shut down
some like the universal Hospital have
been hit by nearby shelling and others
like this one were ambushed by rapid
support forces
staff that were trapped have now fled
their emergency rooms to be with their
families
casualties are redirected to the few
functioning facilities
we need support we need medical supplies
says one volunteer at umdurman teaching
Hospital we've suddenly become surgeons
paramedics whatever is needed and the
casualties are too many to count
you can just hear how frustrated and
overwhelmed he is the things they've
seen over the last few days this is one
of the few hospitals that's remained
open in the capital since fighting
started and they're just overwhelmed 50
of the hospitality is more or less not
functioning either because they were
bombarded because they lack supplies and
they close up because the staff simply
abandoned the hospital
and those that are functioning are like
in field they're like in a medicine
they're like you know they stuff
personnel
where hundreds of thousands of people
already depend on Aid a Doctors Without
Borders medical supplies Warehouse has
been ransacked by armed militiamen
closely affiliated with the rapid
support forces what's your capacity in
Nial at the moment
there's no capacity we lost the capacity
because of this Looting of your supplies
yes yes exactly so for our capacity is
when we have a means to assist the
population if there is no means
basically we we don't have any more
capacity
the rapid support forces have been
looting facilities and homes
the terror they raised in that foot now
spread to the streets of the capital
Sky News